- After Thursday's snow storm,
the snow in Chillytown
was 55 centimeters deep.
On Friday, the snow kept coming
and several more centimeters fell.
So, okay, they're getting a lot of snow.
Now, the snow in Chillytown
is 84, 84 centimeters deep.
How many centimeters
of snow fell on Friday?
So let's look look at this diagram again,
just so that we can imagine what went on.
So, the first time...
So the snow in Chillytown...
There's a storm on Thursday,
and then the show in Chillytown
was 55 centimeters deep
and they show that to us right over here.
So this is the 55 centimeters,
is this point on the ruler.
So this is how deep,
this is how deep the
snow was after the storm,
after the storm on Thursday.
This is how deep.
So this depth right over
here is 55 centimeters.
But the snow did not stop, it kept coming.
So now the snow in Chillytown
is 84 centimeters deep.
So in the ruler, that's
this right over here,
84 centimeters deep.
So they wanna know how many centimeters
of snow fell on Friday.
So they want us to figure out
what is this amount right over here?
What is the amount that fell on Friday?
They even put the question
mark right over here.
Question mark centimeters.
So how do we figure that out?
Well, let's just right some...
Let's write some things
that we know are true.
So we know that 55 centimeters...
55 centimeters, plus however
many centimeters this was,
so I'll write question centimeters.
So this is how many were
after Thursday's snow storm,
plus however many fell on Friday.
We don't know that, so I'm just gonna
write a question mark over there.
That's going to be equal to the total.
That's equal to 84 centimeters.
So we just need to figure out
what's this question mark.
Well, one way to figure out
what this question mark is
if 55 plus question mark
is 84, then that means,
that means that 84 minus 55,
minus 55 is going to be
equal to the question mark,
is going to be equal to the question mark.
And one way to think about it is,
if you had all this snow and you were to
subtract out 55 centimeters of it,
you're just going to be left
with the question mark amount
because the difference between 84 and 55
is what fell on Friday.
The difference between 84 and 55.
So let's figure out what that is.
So I can do that.
I'm running out of space
here, I'll do it down here.
So we have 84, 84
minus 55, minus 55,
and that's going to be
equal to our question mark.
So let's look at our ones place.
We have four ones minus five ones.
Well, since we don't know how to do that,
since four is less than five,
so let's regroup.
So let's take a 10 from the 10s place.
Instead of having eight 10s there,
let's have seven 10s there
and then make that extra 10 we just took,
turn that into 10 ones.
So 10 plus four is 14.
So now we can subtract.
14 ones minus five ones.
Let me move down a little bit.
14 ones minus five ones is nine ones.
Seven 10s minus five 10s is two 10s.
So our mystery amount
of snow, 29 centimeters.
So this right over here is 29 centimeters.
And you can check that.
55 plus 29 is indeed equal to 84.
I encourage you to try to check
that that does definitely work.
So how many centimeters
of snow fell on Friday?
29, 29 centimeters.
The important thing for problems like this
is just imagine the story.
Imagine what's going on,
and then draw diagrams
if they didn't draw it for you,
and then think about writing
some math statements.
Some people would call
them number sentences
or equations that you
know are going to be true
and then you can figure
out what you don't know.